en eeuu el voto es sagrado así es como
la gente de esa nación expresa su
voluntad y es la voluntad de los
votantes de nadie más de nada más lo que
elige al presidente de los estados
unidos de américa entonces
cada voto debe ser contado y eso es lo
que vamos a buscar en esos momentos y
eso es lo que debe ser la democracia a
veces es un poco desorganizada a veces
requiere algo de paciencia también pero
esa paciencia ha sido recompensada ahora
por más de 240 años persiste más del
gobierno al sistema del gobierno y esto
ha sido el vídeo del mundo un quinquenio
y seguimos sintiéndonos la senadora y yo
nos sentimos muy bien y c's por cómo
están las cosas en estos momentos no
tenemos duda de que cuando se termine la
cuenta la señora gervis y yo seremos
declarados ganadores entonces le pido a
todos que mantengan la calma a todos que
mantenga la calma el proceso está
funcionando
la cuenta está siendo completada y lo
sabremos muy pronto así que gracias a
todos
su paciencia dios los bendiga a todos y
nos protejan esas tropas muchas gracias